you as regulators say Boeing 737 max
Jets will not be cleared for use before
the end of this year they've been
grounded around the world since March
following two deadly crashes the Federal
Aviation Administration says there are a
number of milestones still to be
completed before they can return to the
skies talking of the skies air travel is
responsible for around two-and-a-half
percent of global co2 emissions and yet
despite the climate crisis more and more
people are traveling by plane passenger
numbers have risen steeply over the last
few years particularly in Asia the rise
in air travel is good news for the
leading aircraft manufacturers airbus
has plenty of orders to fill in the next
two decades european air travel is
expected to double
many large airports are being built
across asia including beijing 'he's
dashing airport once completed it will
boast four runways last year the
asia-pacific region has the largest
share of international air traffic with
almost 34 percent followed by Europe
with 26 percent and North America with
just under 23 percent Africa lagged far
behind with just 2 percent but the
sector is likely to grow rapidly in some
African countries this year
Uganda relaunched its state carrier
Uganda Airlines after it was grounded
for 17 years other countries like Rwanda
have high hopes for their national
carriers but most of them are mired in
heavy debt air fares are too high for
many consumers and the route networks
are limited and complicated last year
nearly 30 percent of seats on African
flights were empty